>> Tucker: HAS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS GOT
HOOKED ON OPIOIDS, ONE FAMILY
RAKED IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM THEIR SUFFERING.
BUT THEY DIDN'T ACT ALONE.
AN INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST HAS
WRITTEN AN ENTIRE BOOK ON THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC WITH A
FASCINATING CONVERSATION.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> 2007, PURDUE HAD TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO FELONY MISBRANDING,
MISREPRESENTING THE DRUG IS NOT
ADDICTIVE ENOUGH AND TO SAFE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, $600 MILLION
FINES, PAID BY THE TOP THREE
EXECUTIVES AND IF WE SPOKE THE
WEEK AFTER THAT, I WOULD'VE SAID
TO YOU IT'S OVER, DOESN'T
MATTER, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
SELL BIG NUMBERS ANYMORE AND
WHAT I HAVE BEEN WRONG BECAUSE
AFTER THEY PLEAD GUILTY AFTER
THIS AGREEMENT, AFTER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
SUPPOSED TO WATCH THEM, THEY
HAVE THEIR BIGGEST SALES FROM
2008 ON, BRING IN THE GREAT FIRM
TO SAY WE NEED THE BIG GUYS
HERE, WE NEED McKENZIE AND
McKENZIE TELLS THEM HOW TO
TURBOCHARGE SALES IN 2013 WHEN
SALES ARE DOWN $100 MILLION AND
EVERY YEAR TAKING OUT
800 MILLION, A BILLION IN 2015,
THEY MAKE THE FORUM'S WEALTHIEST
FAMILIES AND FORBES CALLS THEM
THE OXLEY CLAN.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES
McKENZIE TELL THEM?
>> THIS IS FANTASTIC.
I TOLD THEM YOU NEED TO INCREASE
THE SALES REPRESENTATIVES WHO
WERE GOING OUT, THE DETAIL TEAM,
THOSE THAT ARE SELLING THE DRUGS
DIRECTLY TO DOCTORS BY 20%, MAKE
THEM MAKE MORE VISITS AND DON'T
HAVE THEM WASTE THEIR TIME ON
THE LOW PRESCRIBING DOCTORS
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WORTH IT.
GO JUST FOR THE HIGH
PRESCRIBING, GO TO THE ONES WHO
ARE.
>> Tucker: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO FIRST READ ABOUT THE
STORY 20 YEARS AGO SAID TO
THEMSELVES THAT'S REALLY SAD
PEOPLE ARE DYING OF DRUG ABUSE
AND ATTICS O.D. AND THEY ARE
ADDICTS AND YOUR SYMPATHY IS
LIMITED BECAUSE THEY ARE AN
ADDICT AND THEY ARE REVILED.
MY MIND WAS CHANGED WHEN I READ
THE NUMBERS, THE NUMBERS OF
PILLS COMING INTO CERTAIN ZIP
CODES PARTICULARLY IN APPALACHIA
AND KENTUCKY AND WEST VIRGINIA
AND PARTS OF OHIO WERE SO HIGH,
IT DIDN'T SEEM TO ME THAT ANY
HONEST AND DECENT PHARMA
EXECUTIVE COULD READ THESE IN
THE MONTHLY REPORT AND THINK
THAT WAS OKAY.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
HE CAN'T GET AWAY WITH IT.
THEY KNEW WHERE THERE WAS HEAVY
CONCENTRATIONS, THEY NEVER
REPORTED ANY OF THIS TO THE FDA,
NEVER REPORTED ANYTHING BACK,
THEY JUST PUT ON THEIR BLINDERS
AND SAID LET'S POCKET THE MONEY.
THERE'S A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY
THAT GOES AROUND, IT IS THE FDA,
THE MIDDLE DISTRIBUTORS, DOCTORS
RUNNING PILL MILLS, PHARMACISTS
WHO ARE WILLING TO CUT THE ROLES
AND LOOK THE OTHER WAY TO FILL
THE PRESCRIPTION THAT SHOULDN'T
BE DONE THOUGH THEY WILL TAKE
THE BRUNT OF THE BLAME BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE OWNERS OF THIS STAR
DR